derrière cette porte les échanges sont
vifs parfois houleux laissant place à de
l'agacement et de la colère des
représentants de salariés leurs avocats
et en face un candidat repreneur le
groupe d'octogénaires son partenaire
attire spécialiste du traitement de
l'insuffisance rénale une association
qui a surpris ses salariés mais qui est
selon ce nouveau candidat
un des points forts de son argumentaire
nous avons besoin d'installer une de nos
unités à l'intérieur d'un établissement
où il ya un plateau technique suffisant
pour répondre aux besoins de nos malades
nous traitions de maladies chroniques
des causes de l'insuffisance rénale et
que c'est un afflux de malades
supplémentaires que nous pouvons
apporter notre groupe avec sa puissance
là ce sera tir avec sa crédibilité
territoriale somme de nature à pouvoir
apporter ses sûreté aux salariés autre
point fort selon ce repreneur
l'exploitation de 11 cliniques et
hôpitaux 17 centres de santé centre
dentaire optique et thermales dans plus
de quinze départements
en martinique il mise sur un partenariat
privé public que nous pensons que pour
le bien-être des martiniquais il faut
une plage popularité de l'offre de santé
il faut pas qu'il ya un monopole de
l'offre de santé privés l'hôpital public
va très mal et donc il faut chercher des
partenariats avec l'hôpital public
mais le personnel est inquiet pour son
avenir
ce monsieur nous dit qu'il va licencier
le personnel de la maternité parce que
la maternité est fermé je l'entends bien
je l'entends bien que le personnel mais
j'ai quand même fait neuf licenciés j'ai
fait la famille des rien donc je ne peux
pas clos avec des repreneurs qui me
disent que je vais prendre ce vol et au
bout d'un an
ces salariés sont sont dans la rue donc
il faudrait que j'arrive avec des
dossiers clé ce que je n'ai jusqu'à
maintenant je n'ai pas de cycle et nous
n'avons pas de garantie suffisante sur
les conditions de la problématique des
investissements que nous n'avons pas de
certitude écrites concernant le
personnel qui va être gardé et nous
avons une inconnue totale du prix de
cession qui sera proposé ce repreneur
est le deuxième candidat intéressé par
la reprise de la clinique sainte marie
avant lui la cnic saint paul s'est
manifesté avec une offre qui semble
mieux convenir à ses salariés
il ya un montant de cinq cent mille
euros du 2 de 10 milles via deuxièmement
la garantie de garder la quasi totalité
des salariés sur ceux qui sont attachés
à la maternité gars dû fermer et vias
nombre d'engagements sur des
investissements chiffrés que décidera le
tribunal de commerce mardi prochain un
plan de continuation de cap à l'actuelle
direction ou bien le rachat de la
structure par un nouveau repreneur
les 171 salariés s'interrogent